but what if you're like like he said
he's married and he let the baby
starve that makes a good story she got
ttty
[Music]
milk uh members of our Discord get to uh
ask us certain questions and we actually
got a really uh a very serious question
and if you want to join the the Discord
real quick you you got to join our
patreon that's the only way we're going
to talk to
you PM us but so I'm glad we have you
guys here cuz I think you'll have a
better answer than any of us for this
guy why why do you think they're
smar all right fine let's try this then
don't answer the first time give it to
them let them go first right we'll be
the judges first let them go first we
got dumbass versus UTI damn it I mean
we're called UTI man that [__] is UTI is
the worst AR I did think it was your tra
infection at first and then somebody
today in the comments was like but the
but the acronym fits you guys so well
what that I was like [__] you trying to
say damn all right this guy's name is
zal and um so he's he's a male he's 25
he's married trying for a baby soon damn
married at 25 yeah yeah yeah spent his
whole life not knowing what he wanted to
do he's always followed his parents plan
for how his life supposed to go sounds
Asian and he's now just starting to be
sick of it and he said he just realized
he has a passion for forensic science
that's cool and he wants so bad to chase
that dream the problem is that he
already Works in it and he has a good
job that pays well and he gets to work
from home golden handcuffs listen to
your parents dude stop man just stop
dreaming wow wow let him go first oh
yeah I was just reading what Nick was
about to say so he said if he were to
chase the passion then he would need to
go to adult school and like go to school
all over again but the problem is he'd
also have to take really basic courses
so it would take a while uh 2 to 4 years
and he said that he feels like his life
is wasting weight if he doesn't do this
oh he said have you guys experienced the
same thing or am I just being an
ungrateful little [__] I'm going
through every day at work unhappy and
unmotivated this [__] stresses me out I
need me some Nong shim for
real dude this man talks like he's like
80 years old he's 25 that's exactly what
I'm saying if he wanted to do whatever
the hell he wanted to do he should do it
yeah because or else he's always going
to regret it true he yeah yeah when he's
30 he's goingon to be like oh I wish I
did it and then when he turns 40 he's
going I wish I did like like you're
going to keep talking about the same
[__] like stop complaining and just do
it and I feel like I feel like a lot
this happens to most people in that
situation you grow up and then if you
don't address like that resentment you
feel for your parents that you may have
it may have come from a good place but
if you just let it keep stacking like
you're going to start blaming them and
for the sake of you and your parents'
relationship I would suggest doing
whatever makes you if if you feel that
strongly about it I don't know why you
pick forensic science of all things but
like he likes dead bodies I also I also
would say he mentioned that that already
like his his field of work like he
dreads it it's it's a terrible feeling
waking up every day and dreading being
alive that [__] kills you quicker than
anything that's a silent killer so yeah
exactly if you have to go back to school
and blah blah blah restart your life at
25 you're you're so young 25 feels
that's young literally and this is like
2 years like how much exactly like I
hated school so I quit school and look
at me now I'm on UTI y realiz when she
gets drunk she gets aggressive really I
just want to beat everyone
upy fire she's aggressive overall she
just be holding it back for our sake
usually I know when I get home you know
what I do did any of you guys have a
previous like either career or something
that you hyper focused on that you had
to leave in order to do what you do now
I'm just selling weed okay but that's a
highly profitable thing that you would
have to stop doing I was at home
chilling you were what I was at home
chilling yeah actually I I'd say
Jeremy's the one situation that would
fit this cuz I was a bartender but I
love bartending like I took it as far as
I possibly could but uh so you stayed
and progressed your career cuz now you
have a high level still brought to you
by nectar heart C flavor no weird
aftertaste but but for like Jeremy for
example he was in the music industry as
a talent manager and he hated that [__]
yeah so he despised it I hate Talent
managing
too I'm the talent he's like I hate
managing my own Talent like so hard so
he left an industry completely and he
wanted to do he wanted to do [__] by his
own terms and that's how nectar was born
right and it's like and you and there is
obviously worry of like stability like
all of these things but at the end of
the day like if you have these emotions
that don't go away because you're just
not in the right place in life like you
got to step into your true being I think
and then and also Jeremy started this
pretty pretty later in life yeah that
what age was it 28 29 I think was when
the idea first came but he like it
launched like 2020 nectar lunch yeah
only a few years ago well done wow okay
guys
is [__] dude now that you've heard that
side we're going to hear from uh the gay
dumb asses over here I think you should
just added gay they're the dumbest man
you said it was the gay side early no I
didn't say I said the dumbest the
dumbass dude you got to pick one we
can't be both okay some of us are both
which one do you want I'm both um I
think he should just [__] shut up and
just crush his own dreams and just keep
going to what was it it it keep doing it
keep doing it keep doing it you'll be
fine just just power through power
through if you're 25 dude it's already
[__]
over you have [__] nothing left old
you're [__] old you think 25 is too
late he should be signed up for his
Social Security that's all what age
would not be too late to change careers
n like 17 dude probably 17 or 18 he's
[__] he's [__] washed dude this
guy's 25 he's washed need you'll never
[__] make it science you turn 18 and if
you already made your decision by that
time what I would do is at at your it
work go to the top floor of the building
and see if it's really high or not yep
and look if it's two stories don't even
try it don't even try it don't even
[__] try it but if it's if it's
really really high then maybe take a
leap of faith and see what happens you
might land in the the forensic signs
building very unlikely but just try it
he'll definitely be in forensic science
one way or another literally wow Anthony
what do you think let me tell you you
stupid [__] what skip Anthony
yeah let's seear what Joe has to say
skip go ahead anony go ahead gay dumb
ass no that's me
dude Mr Colonel Sanders was 40 years old
when he made KFC but he wasn't
successful at 40 this [__] was
probably about 60 to 70 years old
geriatric when he finally made it with
KFC okay and how much do we do we love
KFC love it but he died before everybody
could love it you guys love KFC but I
thought he was trying to do chicken
already I like Bojangles more more of a
churches guy but the point
is there's no time on this [__] never a
time limit on your but what if you're
like like he said he's married and let
the baby
starve that's makes a good story she got
titty milk that [__] baby don't need its
own food just [__]
she got at least a year have an Atkins
baby bro like if he's going to school
for like what a year you don't need that
much school for forensic science that sh
is a [__] science anyway and then
you just you just go work at a police
station or whatever and then you can
find you know you can go to Crime scen
someone got blasted you just do the
chalk around the bullet and [__] you
don't do jack [__] take some pictures on
your [__] phone and then you
fingerprints dust it put the it's a
[__] degree dude you could finish
that in the year baby comes out all it
needs is take milk which your wife
produces it's free you don't got to pay
for anything you're [__] tripping for
no reason also does his wife work or is
he like f matter of fact make the wife
pay for [__] get on welfare you should
get a divorce how about that there's no
shame in going on welfare to be honest
if you need to do it do it also you know
if if that whole forensic [__] doesn't
happen then just go back to honestly
find a new dream why why forensic sign
why why don't you just go back try it
and then go back that [__] I feel like
he's lying to us cuz where where have
you ever heard my pass for forensic
science that's code for only fans oh is
it yeah do only fans then that can't
wait to go [__] look at a wall that
has bullet holes and ride chalk around
it and circle the crime [__] that's all
he wants to do you have a good weap the
entire industry yeah I I do think a lot
of people do get caught up cuz I relate
to them actually like I I was an
undergrad we were trying to figure out
if you want to do JK fulltime I was
doing that whole [__] Premed route
and then at that time I I think I really
hated my life mhm but I didn't know like
the words depression or whatever and I
probably was depressed like probably my
whole life cuz I I felt like I was
living my parents' dream and I remember
like when we started doing JK it was the
first time that like I had like a breath
of fresh air like oh [__] you can do
yeah you can do things for yourself and
it was like a light that I never it's a
beautiful feel yeah I felt ever before
in my whole life yeah so like people
they think oh [__] it's such a long time
yeah maybe you are [__] [__] it
takes you four years to learn how to
feather dust and [__] yeah like me but
you could you could learn how to do it
in the one year and one year is a short
time different
fingerprints duster for a lifetime of
like brightness and happiness
fulfillment a short yeah dude yeah you
you remember I was like not work not a
full-time Dan yeah so I was like working
in sales then I was in tech as well then
I went to like another sales job for a
clothing brand but I was watching all my
homies around me living the dream and
like pursuing their passion like this
guy well yeah because I I actually got
to know him as a whole different guy I
was like dude you're gay yeah that too
how wait what did you know him as like a
UCI dancer or not because first I knew
in in uh when he was like before he
graduated I just knew him as like oh he
dances for fun and then everyone around
us we all shifted to dancing for career
but he went to work like work work and
he's right he he didn't make it when you
guys made it no ended up in the same
shitty spot though huh
Joe jokes on you but then it's true we
we were all like damn like together it's
crazy to see somebody that you know is
so good and then they're just not doing
the thing it's like if if his friends
knew that he was a forensic scientist
[__] genius genius and he's just
doing y'all know how to dance why not
just hop on Tik Tok he is he is on Tik
Tok cuz I'm 37 and over it
[Laughter]
bro that's true we just had Michael here
and man I was like damn dude I might
start dancing on Tik Tok that sounds
crazy you made3 million be the same
fucking3 million
dollar but yeah there there was just
that feeling of like watching your
homies do what they love and then you be
in a spot where you weren't doing what
you love you know what I mean so just
like just like B said once you actually
go for it even though there's nothing
but uncertainty there there's that
Breath of Life that finally comes and
you're like wao like I can actually do
something that I want to do you know so
you got to try it even if doesn't work
out and then you know worst casee
scenario you end up at like JK or some
[__] but what if you had like a wife
already at that point and a baby on the
way does that change your priority of
like all the only advice or things that
I've heard from people that are like
about to have a baby is all the dudes
are always like I never knew that there
was like a seventh gear that I could
have yeah you know what I mean so like I
I look forward to that possibility like
the idea that you think that you're
going hand but until you actually live
your life not for yourself anymore but
for somebody else that you created you
can only imagine how gangster you're
going to be yes at least it's real at
least it's like something where you can
get a career and so it's like it's like
he's going from what does he do some
computer it it so he does that and he's
going to go that into forensics where
there's jobs for it's not like you're
going to be a professional
juggler or like your wife is like Magan
that's why it feels fake to me cuz like
what is this practical ass dream you
know what I mean it's way too practical
so practical I'm sure there's some
transferable skills from his it job to
it sounds like to me who a doctor that's
going you know what I really wanted to
do Dentistry but like I'm out here
[__] at the ER and I hate my life
you're just switching from one realistic
career to another one but then he he
would take two to four years not working
to have to like go to school wait why
doesn't he he has work I mean I guess he
could but then yeah why can't he I went
to school and had two jobs it's like you
can do it too dude everything's online
now bro [__] Community local
Community College you can take Basic G
that's an excuse that's an excuse but is
his job hella tax in like it's 50 hours
a week crazy get a new job yeah get a
part time take a take a pay you know B
pay bump down and [__] find do some
nice all right that's very different
from what you said earlier I like it no
actually [__] that guy he's an
idiot he's a patron say loving stuff no
I love that guy he's going to be fine
he's going to be fine Sherlock Holmes
you're okay when you're out there
investigating right now you see a
[__] finger on the floor at a crime
scene and then you put that [__] you're
going to put in the bag the evidence bag
you're going to be like JK was right
thank you guys I feel fulfilled I bet
you I bet you he just wants to be like a
lab analyst like he's probably not the
chalk guy no there's only the chalk and
the feather duster okay so yeah Z you
heard it from two amazing sources uh
they're both pretty much saying follow
your heart do what you want to do if
you're doing a job that's going to end
up making you want to kill yourself then
yeah get out of there man watch he fails
and he gets mad at us and [__] he blames
you he's only he hates his new forensic
science job
this job sucks I'm making half the money
double the work like [__] this
[__]